Several factors conspire to make
this process of classification
much more complicated.
This is as you would expect in AI.
If it was an easy problem
it would not be part of AI.
The first factor that makes this problem
complicated is that one data point
might be explained by
multiple hypotheses.
So I go to the doctor with high fever,
D5 here,
and several hypotheses about different
diseases might explain my high fever.
Which of this hypotheses, then, is true?
A second factor that
complicates things is
that one hypotheses may
explain multiple sets of data.
So the hypotheses that
Ashok has influenza
might explain not only that he has
fever, but also that he feels tired, and
also that he is shivering, and
also that he can't sleep at night.
Go to your doctor with two data items,
one that have high fever and
the other that I am tired.
Now the doctor may come
up with a hypothesis, H3,
that Ashok suffers from flu.
However, when H3 is present,
then one can expect other
symptoms to be observed as well.
However, the hypothesis of H3
may generate expectations but
additional data items.
How, then,
may a doctor decide if H3 is true?
Well, one possibility is that
a doctor may ask Ashok additional
questions to collect additional data.
Do you shiver at night, the doctor may
ask, if that is one of the expectations
generated by the hypothesis
of having flu.
because the mapping is not only from
the data space to the hypothesis space,
the mapping is also from the hypothesis
space to the data space.
Diagnosis entails not only mapping
data to hypothesis, but also to
know the expectations of additional data
and, collecting that additional data.
Of course, both of the first two factors
may be present at the same time.
That is, one hypothesis may
explain multiple data items.
And multiple hypothesis may
explain the same data item.
So, in general,
this is a M to M mapping, multiple
hypothesis, multiple sets of data.
And, of course, this immediately
makes the diagnostic task harder.
The fourth factor that makes
the diagnostic task hard is that
these hypothesis could
interact with each other.
One of the common interactions between
hypotheses is called mutual exclusion.
Mutual exclusion occurs if
one hypothesis present,
another hypothesis cannot be true.
In this case, H3 explains D2, D3, D4.
And H6 expands D of 6, D of 7, D of 8.
But if H3 is present, H6 cannot be true.
And if H6 is present, H3 cannot be true.
This makes the diagnostic task hard
because if a patient goes to a doctor
with symptoms D3, D4 and D6, D7, then
the question becomes whether to include
H3 or
to include H6 to define our conclusion.
A fifth factor that makes the diagnostic
test hard is called cancellation.
Cancellation occurs when
two hypotheses interact
relative to a particular data item.
As an example, I may have flu, which
tends to increase a temperature, but
I may also have a lowered
immune function,
which tends not to show
higher temperature.
As a result, I may not show high fever,
but it's not because I don't have flu.
It's much more because
the symptoms of flu and
the symptoms of lowered immune function
are cancelling out each other.
>> So, we also saw this
in our initial exercise.
We chose Thetadesis as the most
parsimonious hypothesis for these data.
But imagine if we didn't
have that as an option.
If we didn't have Thetadesis, we may
have said that it's Betatosis, Iotalgia,
and Kappacide, because the elevated
A we see in Iotalgia cancels out
the reduced A we see in Kappacide, which
would account for our normal A levels.
>> In general, cancel interactions
are very hard to account for.
In order to address these
factors that make diagnosis so
complex, it is useful to shift from
the perspective of diagnostics solely
as classification to a perspective
of diagnostics as abduction.